They're all jumbled,
they're all jumbled together,
but they really are associated with both
my grandmothers.
Um,
my father's mother who died when I was
pretty young,
I do remember going into her house and
she lived in a walkup tenement in the
bronx where my father grew up.
She lived in the same apartment in which
my father grew up.
Um,
and I do remember her making blitzes are
Paragi or something like that from
scratch,
making the dough,
rolling it out,
filling it with cheese or potatoes and
cooking them in that.
No,
that was pretty incredible because I
don't have,
my mother didn't do that stuff,
so I don't have a lot of that,
but I have that little bit of that.
And then my other grandmother,
she was the one who really did the big
family functions and would cook for 15
and 20 people at once and would scream
at everybody in the kitchen and Dadada.
And she made.
She made very,
very classic Eastern European Jewish
food and,
and was good at it.
Um,
I don't remember anything particular
mean.
I remember eating many different things.
I don't have a single memory though.
Um,
it's kind of self defense.
I,
um,
I grew up in New York and the food was
interesting,
varied,
not particularly great at home,
but out on the streets it was good.
And in some of my friends' parents
houses it was good.
And um,
then I went away to school in
Massachusetts where the food was
abysmal.
Um,
and I started cooking out of self
defense.
I mean,
it's just the only way I could imagine
to get halfway decent food was to learn
how to make it myself.
And it really began there.
And then,
um,
continued through a series of roommates,
some of whom cooked in,
some didn't,
but all of whom were interested in what
I,
what I was cooking,
sorry,
it's just following recipes.
I mean,
there was no training but they were good
recipes.
So it worked.
And then,
um,
then I had a child who started cooking
for her and then,
and then I started writing about food.
At that point I knew it had been eight
or 10 years.
Then I knew enough about food to write a
little about it and then no pun
intended,
they fed off of each other.
So I was writing about food and I was
cooking and I had to cook in order to
write better about food.
So there's incentive to cook more,
which gave me more to write about.
There you have it.
I still have not ever had any formal
training.
Well,
let's just distinguish between chefs and
cooks because I think this is important.
And a chef,
as a person,
I,
you know,
I know that word is thrown around a lot,
but a chef as a person who runs the
restaurant,
so people who cook at home or cooks,
there's nothing wrong with that.
Um,
people who like to cook our cooks and I,
you know,
I think that that's a word that's been
sadly denigrated.
And um,
um,
I think it's a lovely word.
It's an important word.
So what are the most experience,
what are the most important techniques
for,
shall we say,
novice cooks?
I'm
well reading I think is probably a very
important technique because probably the
best way to learn how to cook remains
getting a couple of decent cookbooks and
working your way through them and paying
attention to what they're asking and
learning a few of the terms and,
and,
you know,
it's,
it's such an easy,
it's so much easier than playing tennis,
for example,
that um,
it's just a matter of starting to do it
and then doing it over and over again
until you kind of get it.
So it has more,
it's presented as a highly skilled
occupation and indeed for real chefs or
people running restaurants or people
doing demonstrations on food television,
it's not that easy,
but for most of us it's not any harder
than driving a car.
It just needs a little practice off the
top of my head without looking at my
pantry.
A garlic olive oil.
That's too,
um,
it,
it sort of,
it's a hard question because do you want
to count rice and Pasta?
Do you want to count vinegar and Lemons?
Do you want to count onions and eggs?
Maybe that gets you close to 10.
The thing is that there are,
I would say there are probably 30,
somewhere between 25 and 50,
but say 30 ingredients that should be
pretty much in every kitchen all the
time.
Ten is not going to do it.
You can't,
you can't do much with 10,
but if you have 30,
you can start doing serious cooking and
if you have those 30,
um,
and you stop at the store and pick up a
piece of meat or fish and some
vegetables,
something fresh,
you're completely in business.
You can cook half of what there is to
cook in all over the world.
That's an interesting question.
People don't use high enough heat,
uh,
and people don't preheat their pants and
their ovens and things like that enough.
Um,
if you really want to,
if you really want to put a crust on
something,
the pan needs to be hot.
The butter oil needs to be hot.
I mean,
these are things that trained people.
Learn home.
Cooks are a little afraid.
Tend to be a little of a beginning home.
Cooks tend to be a little afraid of high
heat,
so that's a mistake people make.
Having lousy knives is a mistake people
make and it's not.
It's not that they don't have expensive
knives,
it's that they don't have sharp knives.
On the other hand,
spending too much money on cooking
equipment.
This is a mistake a lot of people make
because you don't need to a lot of money
on cooking equipment.
What else can I think of?
Well,
attitude.
Attitude is interesting because,
um,
people tend to be intimidated by cooking
and there's nothing to be intimidated by
it.
As I said at the beginning,
it's really pretty simple.
So the right attitude is the attitude of
I'm going to get something going on,
it's going to be good.
It's not,
oh,
I'm afraid of this,
but nor is it.
Oh,
I'm going to be bobby flay and do
something breathtaking.
It's just going to be.
I'm going to try to,
just like my grandma had cooked for my
mom,
I'm going to try to cook for my friends
or my kids or whatever,
which is,
you know,
normal food,
the food you like.
Well,
spices in general go under appreciated
by American cooks.
I mean the spices that that most
Americans used in cooking tended to be
the sort of,
you might call them warm spices are
sweet spices,
like the kind of stuff you put an apple
pie,
cinnamon,
all spice,
nutmeg,
cloves,
ginger,
a little bit of chilies are certainly
becoming more and more popular in.
That's great.
Um,
mild chili powders is a wonderful
ingredient that's still not fully
appreciated.
P,
mentone,
which is mild smoked Paprika,
which is a form of Chili,
so mild smoked chili patterns,
Spanish ingredient,
really fabulous.
All the Indian spices or Asian spices,
however you want to call them,
tend to be under appreciated it.
And these are really simple things to
use.
I think part of the problem is when you,
when you add four or five spices to a
recipe,
makes the recipe look long,
makes the ingredient list look,
look long,
and no one wants to see a long
ingredient list.
So when writing recipes,
one has to be careful,
but you know,
spices are really,
if you replace them every now and then
so that they're fairly fresh,
they're there,
they're easy to use,
it's not a big deal and they make a huge
difference.
I often don't figure out what I'm
cooking until an hour before people come
over,
but I make sure there's food in the
house and that.
I think that's an important,
you know,
it's,
it seems so obvious when you say it,
but so many people don't do it if you
have a lot of food in the house,
cooking as much easier because now you
have so many options.
Plus there's pressure on you to cook
because you don't want the stuff to go
bad.
So what I cook for people pretty much
depends on what I have.
I try to always have,
you know,
something I've made a deal with a friend
who was an architect and he designed an
office for me.
And uh,
the deal was that I was going to cook
dinner for him and his wife and two of
his friends and my wife.
So they're going to be six of us and uh,
we set a date,
I guess he says we set a date and uh,
morning that afternoon actually by 2:00
he called and said,
so what time do you want us to go over?
I'd completely forgotten about it.
So I went shopping and I made,
um,
I ran out to the store.
I came back,
I made,
it was a long time ago,
but,
um,
I made roast chicken with,
with vinegar,
was sort of a classic French recipe,
some kind of potatoes,
a salad and I don't know if I made or
bought a bread and I made chocolate
Mousse for dessert and I did that on
about two hours,
which for me is a lot of,
it's a lot of time in the kitchen for
me.
I don't spend two hours in the kitchen
that often is.
The great thing was the food was not
that great,
but the food was fine.
The great thing was,
hey,
I got away with it,
and B,
they thought it was fantastic and it was
then that I realized that if you cook
for people in your home,
they are,
they're looking forward to it.
B,
they are going to cut you so much.
Slack,
they're going to give you every benefit
of the doubt.
They're going to be grateful and
therefore the food is gonna taste better
than it would if you're in a restaurant
where the server was annoying you and
you knew you were going to spend a lot
of money and you know,
you had to travel to get there and blah
blah.
So I think it was real and that was,
that was probably 12 or 15 years ago.
So it's about halfway into my.
I've been cooking for 40 years,
but so it was a third of the two thirds
of the way into my life as a cook when I
realized that you can do pretty much
anything in your home if you take it
seriously and do it as well as you can
do it and your friends and family are
really going to appreciate it.
Um,
my presence,
I guess there's other kinds of mark
bittman meals.
Well,
I,
you know,
really its simplicity.
It's honesty.
It's,
um,
it's not overdoing it.
It's generally speaking,
it's very few ingredients and very
little technique and not that much time.
And it's.
And it's home cooking.
It's not,
there's nothing fancy about it.
There's no pretense.
I'd like to think there's no pretense.
I mean,
this all,
it sounds too good to be true.
It sounds like better than I am,
but it really is what I do.
So I guess I'll take some credit for it.
I think if you are a true food lover,
you are a healthy eater.
Well,
first of all,
the term Foodie is completely ridiculous
because for someone,
when you meet somebody and they say,
I really love to eat,
I think the appropriate answer is who
doesn't?
So I mean,
look around,
who's,
you know,
who's not a food lover,
everybody's a food lover.
The question is,
do we responsibly due for your own
benefit?
Do you eat for your planets benefit and
the wheat,
the best food possible?
If the answer to all of those things is
yes,
then you're eating well.
If you're eating,
you know if your style of eating is bad
for your body,
if your style of eating is bad for the
planet,
than you are not really eating good
food,
you're eating lousy food and there's,
as we know,
there's plenty of lousy food around the
principled,
the principled way to eat.
If you were going to say,
I want to eat entirely for my own
benefit,
I want to eat entirely for the benefit
of the planet.
I want to eat in the most responsible
way possible to minimize my carbon
footprint,
to minimize my impact overall,
to minimize my effect on animals.
You would be a Vegan.
That's the bottom line.
The veganism is the most principled way
to eat.
That there is from the perspective of
your own body,
from the perspective of the planet,
from the perspective of animals.
Very few people are going to be vegans.
Let's be real.
So,
um,
what's next?
I mean,
on the one hand you have vegans and on
the other hand you have people who eat
whatever they feel like eating.
There's a middle ground.
The problem with the way most Americans
eat right now is that we are about as
far from veganism as we could be,
so a vegan would get 100 percent of his
or her calories from plants.
Most Americans get 90 percent of their
calories from processed food,
junk food and animal products,
so the goal I think is to move in the
direction of eating more unprocessed
plant food than we do now and
everybody's got a different starting
place.
If you read 20 cheeseburgers a week or
the equivalent,
you might look at eating 15
cheeseburgers,
so weak or the equivalent.
If you're eating 15,
you might look at eating 10 and so on,
and I think if people think about what's
best for their body,
what's best for the planet,
the answer is eating unprocessed plant
food and then think about how can I eat
more of that stuff at the expense of me,
which was,
which was the question,
but also at the expensive processed food
and junk food.
The ideas deed as many unprocessed
plants as you can.
What are plants,
plants or vegetables,
fruits,
legumes,
which means beans,
nuts and seeds.
Um,
what am I leaving out?
I think that's about it.
So the idea is to eat as many
unprocessed plants as you possibly can
and to eat those instead of eating
processed foods,
junk foods and animal products.
But works for me.
What's worked for me for just about
three years now.
What works for me is to eat very,
very strict diet of plants only and
unprocessed plants only from the time I
wake up in the morning until dinner
time.
So from the time I wake up until roughly
dark,
I eat a lot of fruit.
I eat a lot of vegetables,
I eat some whole grains and sometimes I
have some beans and that's pretty much
it.
And then at night I eat whatever I want.
And that's the which includes meeting,
which includes wine and which includes
pasta and bread and stuff like that.
That's a huge change for me.
I think that if you think of your diet
as a seesaw with the,
you know,
the animal products,
the process with the junk food on the
heavy side as it is for most people and
the unprocessed plants on the light side
as it is for most people.
I think for me,
my seesaw went from looking something
like this to looking something like
this.
I think that to the extent other people
can eat that way,
they will have a have a lesser impact on
the planet,
improve their health,
probably lose weight,
feel better.
Think I just decided to change the way
because of some of the things we've been
talking about here.
One is that I recognize that I'm one of
the highest contributors to greenhouse
gases and global warming is the is the
industrial production of livestock,
so I decided,
okay,
that was one good reason to eat less
meat.
The other good reasons he lifts me is
that I was in my mid fifties and my
health wasn't what it used to be,
so I was overweight.
I had bad knees,
I had sleep apnea,
I had high cholesterol,
I had high blood sugar or borderline
high blood sugar.
I think that's enough.
So,
um,
I decided to change my diet and it's,
it's so obvious to everyone who pays any
attention to nutrition at all that if
you want to be healthier,
the way to do that is,
you know,
as I've already said,
is to eat fewer animal products than eat
less processed and junk foods.
So I started to do that and,
and it worked.
I lost 35 pounds,
gained five of them back,
but hey,
a slept sleep apnea went away.
I slept better,
my knees bothered me much less.
In fact,
I ran the New York marathon last year,
um,
my cholesterol is back to normal and my
blood sugars back to normal.
So it all worked.
And it's not a coincidence.
I mean,
no one would say it was a coincidence,
actually not.
Um,
there's some things I don't like,
but I think that it's important to
recognize that there's no sort of single
arsenic and cyanide aside,
there's not really a single ingredient
that's going to outright kill you.
I mean,
there's actually some evidence that a
single can of soda can trigger diabetes,
but there's not a lot of eps evidence
about that in general.
One ingredient,
one little kinds of food,
one,
one meal,
one day,
even one week that's not what's
determinant of your overall health or of
your impact on the planet.
What determines is your overall diet and
if it's moving in the right direction,
which for most Americans is towards
plants and away from animal products and
processed foods,
then I think,
you know,
hip,
hooray,
you know,
that's the way to go.
Yeah.
There is a great vegan chef.
Um,
I mean there were a few at this point
and um,
yeah,
I,
I think that it's,
you know,
actually this is an interesting story.
I met a Vegan chef from Japan a couple
of years ago,
tiny tiny woman.
Um,
really interesting and a,
and not a Vegan in her personal life,
but she was a Vegan chef.
She ran it small,
maybe 12 or 20 seat restaurant in Tokyo.
Um,
and everything was strictly Vegan.
And when I found that she wasn't a
Vegan,
um,
I said,
I don't get this.
I mean,
why would you choose to,
it's not a matter of principle for you
because you eat meat,
you eat fish.
Why would you choose to narrow what you
serve your customers when you're
yourself?
Eat from the broadest spectrum possible.
And she said,
it's like pen and ink.
There are people who choose to be
artists and only pen and ink because
they want to narrow the world in which
they're looking at,
so as to more fully explore it.
And I want to narrow the world in which
I'm cooking so I can understand that
better.
And she was an amazing,
amazing chef.
She made great,
great stuff.
I,
you know,
I'd,
I'd be guessing to answer that question.
And um,
it's a confluence of a bunch of things.
I mean,
first off I guess is that we,
we like fads.
I mean,
we like trends,
so here's the one that hadn't been fully
exploited.
Secondly,
food television really had,
has had a huge impact.
I mean cooking and eating as a spectator
sport never before in history.
So that's had a huge impact.
Third,
I think is the kind of
internationalization of food people,
not only people traveling and seeing
food from the rest of the world,
but ingredients and types of cuisines
and restaurants arriving here in
unprecedented numbers.
So I think,
you know,
I guess the short answer is exposure,
but it still doesn't explain.
It doesn't explain.
You're going to walk into a party and
having someone come up to you and say,
I'm a foodie and there's something about
the sort of trendiness.
It's like saying,
you know,
I'm a closed person.
Well,
yeah,
we all wear clothes.
I'm a closed person.
The thing that makes me most upset about
this big fat is that more people are not
cooking.
And that,
um,
I think it's fine to watch other people
cook,
but then people say,
well,
I'm too busy to cook.
And they're too busy to cook because
they're watching people cook on
television.
It doesn't track for me.
I think it's really,
really bad.
Now the one is real and what is not is
really,
really difficult.
That I,
I,
I can't,
I can't answer that.
I don't.
I don't know what's real and what's not.
One has to hope that things that are
certified organic are organic,
but what does organic mean?
It's a,
it's a term that's defined by the United
States Department of Agriculture.
It doesn't mean anything or it doesn't
mean much about how the animals are
treated.
It doesn't really mean much about what
kind or what breed of the animals there
are.
It doesn't mean anything in terms of how
the workers who were raising these
animals or farming these crops are
treated doesn't mean anything about
where the food is from.
So does organic have some meaning?
Yes.
I think the term organic has some
meeting,
but I think that it's not the most
important thing.
I won't go so far as to say that it's a
red herring because I think it's.
There are some important things about
it,
but I will say this,
the most important division in our style
of eating right now is not organic
versus non organic and it's not local
versus non local.
It's plants versus anything else and you
know,
I don't,
I don't mean to be repetitive,
but the message to me,
the message is very,
very clear.
The way that people can eat best is to
eat less crap,
to put it bluntly and crap is processed
food and junk food and you can have
organic process food and you can have
organic junk food and that food is.
Maybe it's a little better than
nonorganic process than junk food,
but it's not good food and that's the
most important lesson we can learn.
I think.
Well,
I,
again,
I think the clear answer is that,
um,
as far as your body is concerned,
a grape from Chile is better than a
cheeseburger from around the corner.
If you're willing to eat turnips,
carrots,
a bread,
you bake yourself frozen meat,
a very limited diet.
You can eat locally almost anywhere,
at least in this country all year round.
And that's great,
but it's expensive.
It's inconvenient than it takes
dedication.
I think it's a swell idea and I think
that ultimately for food to make sense
in this country,
I think we're going to see more
regionalism and less food coming out of
California,
but I don't think we'll ever be at a
place where we see no food coming out of
California unless it falls into the sea.
Of course.
Um,
and I,
and I think that if you're,
if you want to be truly a local,
either,
you're not going to be drinking.
If you're living in the northeast as I
do,
you're not going to be drinking any
coffee.
You're not going to be drinking any
caffeinated tea.
You're not going to be using any olive
oil.
There are a lot of things you're just
going to be missing out on.
That's fine.
If you think that that's the highest
priority.
There are other priorities.
I think I,
I,
I'm a fan of local food.
I really like local food.
But to go back to the discussion of
trendiness in food,
everything need not be taken to an
extreme.
And this is another thing that's being
has been taken to an extreme,
if you know,
if I'm driving say six hours and I
decided to stop at Wendy's or whatever,
I guess there's a twinge of guilt,
but there's also an excuse because
you're away and you know,
you're busy and blah,
blah blah.
And I don't exercise that excuse very
often.
So I don't really feel guilty about.
I think what would make me feel guilty
and I don't do it,
is I'm going to the supermarket and
buying a huge bag of potato chips and
coming home and eating it,
but I don't do it.
So why do they choose?
Because they want something comfortable.
They want something they're familiar
with.
They all want bacon and eggs,
right?
I mean,
I don't.
That's my guests.
Everybody wants for Friday eggs and
butter with unlimited supply of Bacon
and really,
really great toast.
Um,
I would.
Am I being executed?
I have to get the scenarios.
Assuming I'm being executed and I have,
it's not a last meal.
Like I don't want to think about cancer
last meals.
I want to think about execution last
meals.
I would call,
you know,
I'm privileged,
I can do this.
I would call my friend John George
vongerichten and tell him I want him to
cook for me until I tell them to stop.
That would be my last meal,
but I do like the four or six eggs
cooked in a lot of butter with bacon and
really good toast.
I like that too.
I think it's more authentic.
I think that the problem with salt too,
to the extent that there is a problem
with salt and this is not really,
really clear,
but to the extent that there is a
promise,
it's the salt and processed foods.
People who don't eat a lot of processed
foods don't have problems with salt.
People who add their own salt to food
have no problems with salt.
Chefs who make their own chefs in
restaurants who cooked from scratch and
add salt to their taste or to the
perceived taste of their diners are not
adding criminal amounts of salt.
If you want to limit the amount of salt
mix dot McDonald's puts in it's
processed foods,
that's great.
I'd like to limit the amount of food
they can sell,
period.
It's not really a salt problem.
It's an overall food problem.
Well,
I think it is happening,
which is really amazing that the,
um,
the mayor of Philadelphia just proposed
a very,
the,
the proponents of a soda tax or
generally proposing a penny per ounce as
an excise tax,
which means 12 ounce can of soda might
cost the dollar 12 instead of a dollar
and at a 24 pack case of Soda Might
Cross my double in price from a sale
price of two 99 or three 99.
That's really incredible.
The guy in Philadelphia,
I think his name is nutter,
but it's his name.
The guy in Philadelphia is proposing to
cents per ounce,
which is really quite amazing because it
means a dollar can of soda would cross
the dollar and a quarter,
a 32 ounce bottle of soda.
That was a dollar.
It costs a dollar 32 and oh no,
a dollar 64 and so on.
So I think it is happening.
Why is it important?
Soda is the leading source of calories
for Americans.
Americans get seven percent of their
calories from soda,
which is more than they get from any
other single food,
and let's think about this.
It's non-nutritive.
That is to say it has no benefit
whatsoever.
None like it's not harmless,
it's negative.
Secondly,
it's a leading causes of obesity in the
United States.
I mean if obesity is a problem,
you have to look at where the calories
are coming from.
If soda is the number one source of
calories in the United States and it's
not a beneficial sources of calories is
something people can do with that.
So if you're obese and you're looking
for ways to help people figure out what
they can do without soda is a very good
start.
So I think the tax is a very smart
thing.
There's some research that shows that
taxing junk food,
which thought is a junk food tax,
taxing junk food is more likely to help
people eat well.
Then subsidizing healthy food.
The irony is that if you subsidize
healthy food,
people will take the money they're
saving and buy junk food,
which is sad but true.
I think the soda tax makes sense.
I think it's happening,
I think it's going to happen this year
and next year I think it's going to be a
swell of soda taxes and I think once the
greedy state legislatures realized they
can make money on this thing,
it's going to have even more momentum.
I moved this year and I moved from a
kitchen that was six by seven to a
kitchen.
There was a bad eight by eight,
so it's an eight by eight.
Maybe it's seven by seven.
It's 50 something square feet.
Uh,
it has counselors on two sides.
It has a refrigerator on a third side,
has drawers on the fourth side and it
has two doors.
It has a sink and dishwasher and a stove
and it has maybe six feet of counter
space and nothing is fancy,
but it's for me nearly perfect.
I mean,
I wish I could fit more,
like I wish I could fit a table in it
and I wish I could fit more people in it
to hang out with while I was cooking.
But um,
it's,
it's pretty great.
It's really nice,
but there's nothing that was nothing
unusual or remarkable about it.
Um,
this goes back to something I was
talking about before.
The way that recipes happened for me is
shopping.
It all starts with shopping.
So I will go.
I go to China town a lot,
I go to a decent supermarkets,
I go to green markets and I try to buy
everything that looks good that I think
I can cook in the next x days.
Am I cooking at home for the next four
days?
Because to be home for four days in a
row is a lot.
I'll buy four days of food,
but I'll buy a lot and then I will go
home and I will cook what I bought and
almost always a because I have no
patience with cooking from recipes be
because I'm not that methodical.
See,
because I have a bad memory.
I always think I'm making things up.
I can't even do that.
Implicate my own recipes.
What happens is there's this house full
of food and I started cooking in usually
interesting things happened.
I don't know.
Brilliant things don't happen,
but interesting things happen.
Interesting enough to write about.
Evidently,
since people read this stuff,
well I don't really care.
Um,
you know,
if you substitute one,
and if you,
if you are making pasta with Broccoli
and you don't have Broccoli,
you want to make pasta with quality
flour.
Everything about that is the same.
The cooking time,
the technique,
just about everything about it is the
same.
Assuming you know how to Trim Broccoli
and trim quality flour.
Is it a different recipe?
You might say it's a different recipe.
Um,
but almost everything about it is the
same and so wide.
If it's a different recipe,
recipes still good.
I mean,
I like to say you can vary things as
much as you want to,
but you have to remember that you can't
make a roast chicken without chicken.
It's a toss up.
My wife is the greatest dining companion
and um,
you know,
a total joy to cook for and she's a good
eater and really have fun together.
But I have to say that my kids who grew
up eating my food and can call and say,
I'm coming over,
could you make something Asian or I'm
coming over,
I need this pasta dish,
or I'm coming over and could you just,
could we have one of those?
You know,
I,
it's really nice.
I mean like they're grown.
There's a lot of history there and it's
really special to cook for that.
I don't want to have to convince anybody
that what I'm making is good.
I know it's good.
I usually enjoy it.
If someone enjoys eating,
they'll enjoy eating this stuff.
I cook.
If they don't,
something's wrong somewhere.
You know,
there's not,
you know,
Julia child used to say,
the great thing about is you get to eat
your mistakes.
The thing is that if you take care and
cooking and if you know what you're
doing even a little bit,
unless you burn something,
there are very few things that wind up
so bad that you can enjoy them.
Very few.
So,
I mean,
and I,
I,
you know,
I'm,
I'm lucky enough to have been doing this
long enough and writing about it and
learning from other people and thinking
about it so that generally speaking,
the stuff I do is pretty good and the
people I cook for tend to enjoy it.
But I said before,
it's not,
it's not brilliant.
It's not earth shattering,
it's just good food.
No,
Maria and I have known each other
probably 10 years and we've gotten
increasingly busy so we don't see each
other that much.
So it was really a treat to hang out so
much.
And I'm,
I,
I know from my,
the people who I was going to say my
fans,
which I guess is right,
but anyway,
I know from people who've watched
spending on the road again and my other
TV shows that,
um,
everybody thinks that TV is the most fun
thing in the world and everybody's
completely jealous of,
well,
well you got to hang out with Mario and
Gwyneth and this has that beautiful
woman and the food and Spain must be so
amazing.
And the fact that television is a
tremendous amount of work and for every
minute on screen there's an hour of
work,
so for every 60 minutes on screen
there's a week of work and it really is
like that.
So we did huge amount of driving and
there's a lot of setup time and not
exactly rehearsal,
but figuring out what we're going to do.
So none of that was my favorite part.
My favorite part was nighttime when
everything was done and we all got drunk
together.
So that was really great.
And Mario's Mario of course can drink
anyone under the table.
I think he'll admit to this.
I mean it's not an admission.
I think he'll be proud of this.
Whereas I can't drink anyway under the
table.
Plus I go to bed earlier than anybody
else.
I go to bed earlier than anybody.
So we'd finished the shoot.
We'd have a bite to eat,
we'd have a fair amount of wine.
It would be 9:30,
10:30,
1130.
I'd go to bed.
Mario will be up until four in the
morning.
Everyone else was waking up with black
eyes and broken shoulders.
He was always in great shape,
so that was sort of fun.
It was like,
so I could say,
um,
I would cook for Adolf Hitler and
surfing poison.
I could say that.
Um,
I could say quite sincerely.
see,
I don't think you can influence people
really.
I mean,
I,
you know,
the obvious answer and obvious answers I
will.
I would cook for President Obama and set
him straight on a number of issues,
but he's already got a lot of people
setting them straight.
I think the people I'd most like to cook
for,
um,
would it be my maternal grandparents who
I loved very much had been dead a long
time and who I think in some ways we're
responsible a lot for my personality,
for the way I handle myself and also for
my love of food and saying that makes me
think I should go cook for my parents
more often than I do.
They're alive fortunately.
So I'm going to look on well Foodie,
uh,
we should be hearing less about people
being foodies.
Um,
I guess I have to turn that question
around and say I just,
I just really wish that people would
take more responsibility for their own
food.
I wish people would buy their own food
and cook their own food.
Increasingly,
I don't wish restaurants didn't exist.
I wish that people didn't eat 50 percent
of their meals outside of the home.
I wish they had 10 percent of their
meals outside of the home.
That would be the most positive trend
that could possibly happen in food in
the United States.
And when I say eating at home,
I don't mean going to the supermarket
buying some pre prepared food and eating
it at home and I don't mean by microwave
food and reheating it and home and I
don't mean calling for pizza or take out
and eating at home and cooking.
And if people cooked 50 percent of their
meals as opposed to what's probably 20
percent of their sales people really
cook,
60 percent of the meals there would be a
huge impact on both their health and on
the environment and it would be almost
entirely positive.
That's really my most fervent wish.